[Music]
Eleonore come on in well not often you
get to confront your greatest failure
face-to-face good to see you too bud I'm
just dumbfounded as to how this happen
our system has never made a mistake
before it's just not possible and yet
here we are first things first
who are you well my name is Eleanor
shell Straub and some of the info you
had was right I mean flattened by boner
pill truck after dropping margarita mix
in grocery store parking lot that's a
very me way to die but all the other
info was wrong in my defense when I
first arrived and you said you Eleanor
she'll strap our dead and you're in the
good place I had no reason to think that
was a mistake
location and date of birth please
Phoenix Arizona October 14th 1986 so
sorry that's what I used to tell people
when I lied about my age I was born in
1982 you lied so much you forgot your
own birth date not a great start but it
should be enough for Jenna to locate
your file Janet Janet what's that what's
that what's this her memories still
being rebooted because who you know
someone murdered her Janet could you
please locate the file for an Eleanor
she'll strop born in 1982 Phoenix
Arizona USA sure anything else no Janet
this is actually a cactus this might
take a while we retrieve your file I
need to find another way to determine
what kind of person you were this is a
quick little handful of questions
designed to tell whether you're
fundamentally good or bad question
number one
did you ever commit a serious crime such
as murder sexual harassment arson or
otherwise no did you ever have a vanity
license plate like Mama's BMW Lexus for
Liz or boob guy no did you ever reheat
fish
an office microwave you know have you
ever paid money to hear music perform by
California funk rock band the Red Hot
Chili Peppers no did you ever take off
your shoes and socks on a commercial
airline and socks you know who would to
that people who go to the bad place
Eleanor that's the point and unless I
can figure out a compelling reason to
keep you here you will spend eternity
with murderers and arsonists and people
who take off their shoes and socks on
commercial airlines mmm Janet can I have
a glass of water please
here you go oh gosh you said water yeah
I'm so sorry there you go
[Music]
you